so i recently saw stat in a harvard
business review magazine i want to share
with you that's
mind-boggling but before i get into it i
want to ask you a question
and here's what it is you ever wonder
why
uh recently older employees in the
workforce are being hired
by newer younger employees in the
workforce why is this
is it you know the younger generation is
taking over and it's not fair they're
trying to save money and that's what
they're doing
maybe what else could it be do you ever
wonder why certain people
stay in the same position for too long
and they don't get a promotion and they
start
kind of wondering well how come i'm not
getting the next promotion but i should
be getting the next promotion but i'm
not getting the next promotion
you don't see what i've been doing in
the last five ten years but you haven't
been improving a lot
so harvard business review gave an
incredible statistic and here's what it
is let me read it to you
it says they did a market research on 3
500 managers that's 20
2019 survey on 3 500 managers found that
only 29
of new hires have all the skills
required
for their current roles let alone for
future
ones the research finds that in key
functions such as finance i.t
and sales positions filled today you
ready
will require up to 10 new skills
to learn within the next 18 months let
me read that to you one more time
the search finds that in key functions
such as finance it and sales positions
field today will require up to 10 new
skills
in the next 18 months 10 new skills in
the next 18 months pat what do you mean
10 new skills in the next 18 months well
let me ask you a question so this kind
of helps you
see what they mean how valuable is it to
know
and be an expert in myspace right now
like if you know everything about
myspace right now
how useful is it how useful is it to
know how to use aol chat today like
imagine if you were like a killer on the
old chat you know how to go from the
chat room to the other chat we'll have
like 17 of them working
and how to get traffic and people in you
were great at it how useful is that
skill set
now how useful is the skill set of tick
tock today maybe or
you know clubhouse today or maybe a
skill set of knowing how to prospect on
instagram or knowing how to make certain
connection on different platforms that
are out there or recruit
in a creative way instead of just going
through the typical
monster or career builder or ladder or
any of the stuff that's out there
there's a lot of new skill sets you need
to learn so the point is the following
the reason why sometimes older employees
get replaced is because they stop
learning new skill set and the reason
why so many people
in the workforce eventually plateau is
because they think their existing
129 skill sets that they've learned in
the last 10 years
is going to help them get to the next
level in today's economy
that's not how things work things are
moving so fast
that if you don't learn 10 skill sets in
the next 18 months and every 18 months
you ain't keeping up by the way that's
just if you want to keep
up what if you want to compete it's 20
skill sets you got to learn every 18
months
to keep up and compete so if you ever
wonder if some of these guys
in the world of business keep winning at
the highest
level you may want to ask yourself maybe
just maybe they're learning new skill
sets
that they haven't learned before because
they're constantly learning at what i
need to learn today
and even better what do i need to get
better at in the next 12
24 36 months having said that i did a
video a few years ago two years ago
talking about industries that are about
to be disrupted if you've never watched
it before click over to watch it
and for everybody else have a great week
everybody and hopefully you will commit
to learning
10 new skill sets the next six months
not the next 18 months